[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de o en el
estudio rosa félix mañana de martes como
amaneció buenos días raúl pues eso
buenos días pero malas noticias malas
noticias porque rosa tenemos malas
noticias pues por ese día de la
independencia en eeuu marcado por a dos
tiroteos como avanzadas en el
informativo pero uno particularmente
traumático y por eso vamos entonces a
empezar esta revista de prensa con el
tiroteo de el 9 exactamente porque en
highland park unos suburbios en las
afueras de chicago irrumpió pues un
tiroteo de hecho un joven de 22 años que
está bajo custodia policial a disparó a
los asistentes al desfile por el día de
la independencia desde una terraza y
mató al menos a seis personas según el
balance que se tiene en estos momentos
vamos a ver cómo lo repasa parte de la
prensa estadounidense por un lado el
'chicago tribune' titula holiday holder
no como celebración de terror y horror
en la celebración con esta fotografía
tan explícita tan descriptiva de bryant
case la no vemos este agente de policía
poniendo las manos en la cara así como
cochecitos de bebé juguetes que dejó la
gente tirada pues intentando huir a toda
prisa del lugar del tiroteo por otro
lado este 'chicago tribune' también
recoge algunos de los testigos de las
personas que estaban en este desfile y
dice en un instante todo el mundo
entendió la realidad este es el país de
un balde recordemos donde tuvo lugar un
tiroteo en una escuela primaria del
supermercado de búfalo donde también
tuvo lugar un tiroteo de odio también en
el mes de mayo los asistentes cogieron a
sus hijos en brazos y empezaron a correr
dejaron atrás carritos sillines
celulares y carteras era la escena de
una pesadilla como estamos viendo aquí
en lázaro porque no hay que olvidar
exactamente los policías pues son los
que viven de primera mano esto siempre
también son personas seres humanos
paciente luego el wall street journal
con la misma fotografía el tiroteo en el
desfile del 4 de julio deja al menos 6
muertos de esta fotografía de nuevo tan
impactante de bryant castle a por otro
lado el nivel ya cambia la imagen pero
también es una imagen que parece de una
escena de guerra y dice tiroteo irrumpe
en un desfile en un desfile cerca de
chicago mientras que ayuda aceite de
también pone una fotografía en la que
también se ven muchos elementos
infantiles no la ausencia quizás ya de
las personas es quizás más impactante
que haber visto a víctimas o sangre en
primer plano rosa vamos ahora a cambiar
de información 60 años la independencia
de argelia y como la estructura
precisamente la prensa la prensa de ese
país la prensa argelina pues raúl en
primer lugar queríamos empezar a grandes
a grandes agradeciendo a nuestra
compañera mal por la ayuda que nos ha
prestado para preparar este tema
recordar que como decíamos en los
noticieros se cumplen 60 años de
independencia de argelia 20 de los
cuales se fueron bajo la presidencia de
buteflika contra el que recordemos se
levantó el pueblo en el movimiento
conocido como irak en nada 2019 y
recordemos también que el ex presidente
buteflika falleció el año pasado en todo
caso
hoy la prensa no se centran y en crisis
es sociales anida identidad nacional ni
económica sino que destaca el orgullo y
la unidad y ensalza el nacionalismo
argelino empezamos con saab que dice
jasaitis wafd ayer significa al ger y no
enorgullece te y pues vemos este el lobo
que está presente en muchas portadas de
los 60 años de independencia a 1900
1962 al 2022 por otro lado con la misma
foto histórica no creemos aquí abajo
pues esta euforia del 5 de julio de 1962
también titula el medio al jabar que
dice 60 años desde la independencia la
mayor victoria y menciona un poco las
celebraciones que van a tener el lugar
hoy en algeria por otro lado al jabar al
ayum titula 60 años de la independencia
de argelia una gran historia y una nueva
era y dice que la fiesta de la
independencia vine a concluir una larga
trayectoria y también marca la
construcción de un nuevo país por otro
lado hemos seleccionado otros medios
también es el 60 aniversario de la
independencia una libertad a un alto
coste y señala que todavía el
aprendizaje de la historia y la memoria
nacional está muy marcada por el
colonialismo francés y por último
lección andy pando mbps que dice también
con esta foto no tan histórica titula
resistencia esfuerzo y gloria aquí lo
estamos viendo a nuestras espaldas rosa
y precisamente serra mojó un especial de
medio francés mediapart sobre este mismo
tema exactamente y es que el periodista
fabrice arfi bucea en documentos del
archivo nacional francés algunos de los
cuales fueron desclasificados sólo a
finales de 2021 que relatan secuestros
torturas detenciones ilegales y
ejecuciones extrajudiciales por parte
del ejército francés durante la guerra
de independencia de argelia y es que
recordemos que en esa guerra que duró
entre 1954 y 1962 el ejército francés
aplicó lo que se conoce como doctrina de
la guerra revolucionaria no que es una
estrategia militar contra ins
insurreccional que se basa sobre todo en
la existencia de un enemigo interior
porque recordemos que algeria era un
departamento más de francia y pues está
el tipo de estrategia militar está
marcada por el uso de la tortura y de la
inteligencia por parte del ejército y
raúl cabe destacar que esta estrategia
esta doctrina contrarrevolucionaria se
importó o se exportó depende del punto
de vista desde el que lo veamos aquí
américa latina un ejemplo paradigmático
es por ejemplo el de la dictadura de
videla en argentina
gracias a rosa como siempre por toda la
revista de prensa nos vemos mañana con
más y pasamos a saludar en nuestro
primer invitado el día